what have you been up to since we talked
to you last time
man just creating content and trying to
stay ahead of all the madness that we
see in the world not just uh socially
but more specifically from a standpoint
of macroeconomics I mean to your point
about a year ago I think we probably hit
the peak in the the crypto price point
uh with with the I thought it was a
Mania and it doesn't mean that crypto is
not a good idea long term I think that
the crypto space will be very similar to
the railroads in the 1800s and very
similar to the.com
uh bubble that we saw in the late 1990s
and that is to say that it's a great
technology and it definitely has a
future but whenever you see something
brand new like that everyone piles on
and it just turns into a massive massive
massive bubble and uh and that's what
you get you see you get a bunch of
frauds and like uh whether it was Luna
or Celsius or uh you know FTX we'll see
how this all plays out here but uh it's
very easy to do kind of shady business
and to make a lot of money when the tide
is in
but it's like Warren Buffett says when
the tide goes out you see who is
actually swimming naked and uh you know
if the tide goes out and you're still
wearing your swimming shorts then you've
got a good chance to be successful over
the long term because it wipes out all
of your competitors and again that's
exactly what we saw at the railroads we
saw this in the.com bust in fact I would
argue probably the best time to start a
a web type business was back 2003 2004
2005 like two or three years after you
see this massive bust so I I've been I
was pretty critical about
um you know the hysteria that we saw
because to me a year ago it was just so
painfully obvious but now I'm actually
probably on the other side of the boat
saying well wait a minute I know that
there's a lot of frauds out here and
we're gonna have to see how this plays
out we're definitely not at uh a level
where I would consider capitulation but
uh it doesn't mean that there aren't
some interesting things out there and
the lower the price goes uh and the more
frauds and the more bankruptcy
bankruptcies we see
the more interested I get and I think
that's probably key to being a
contrarian indicator or a conferring
investor do you think that the crypto
bubbles completely popped and we've let
all the extra air out of it or do you
see no because I haven't seen
capitulation yet and it doesn't mean
that that we're not at the bottom it's
as usually if you study Financial
history when you see these types of
bubbles you've got to get to a point
where
like no but like everyone that was
really gung-ho about it is is just
swearing it off like uh you know we
never want anything to do with crypto
for the rest of our lives this was
stupid anyone that gets involved is
crazy it's only going to go down from
here it's it's going to go to a zero and
then you see the people like Michael
Saylor as an example I've always said
that uh you know I I really like Bitcoin
uh to have a purchasing power outside of
the commercial banking system that
that's the main reason I like it but I
say for for me knowing when to buy and
sell is all about psychology uh it's
like Jim Rogers says you've got a You've
Gotta Buy panic and sell hysteria
SO waiting for that Panic you know when
does it come if it's an asset that
you're bullish on long term and this is
applicable to oil Commodities stocks
crypto Bitcoin gold it doesn't matter
it's just human psychology and uh so
what I said is when I see Michael Saylor
sell his Bitcoin I'll know that's the
time to buy
right because that will represent
absolute capitulation another thing that
I I thought would be kind of an a lead
an indicator would be the Bitcoin
conference I don't think you've been to
this down in in Florida but I went in
where did I go I it would have been
2021. okay I was at the Bitcoin
conference and it was like a circus I
mean there were 15 20 000 people there
it was it was absolute Madness
a lot of fun but I I tell people you
know follow how many people are actually
attending the Bitcoin conference
annually and when you see that drop from
15 000 down to a thousand that's when
you start to get interested right and
that's when you want to catch it for the
next cycle up but it always goes back to
just Jim Rogers you know he's my
favorite investor and if people can just
ask themselves okay am I seeing absolute
Panic right now or am I selling seeing
absolute hysteria and if you're not
seeing one of those two things then you
usually just sit on the sidelines
okay that's an interesting angle do you
think that Bitcoin is the same as
cryptocurrencies or is it uh completely
separates just a commodity
I I do not I think Bitcoin is definitely
Superior uh to the other
cryptocurrencies uh especially if you're
talking about the just the jokes like
Dogecoin or Shibu Inu or you know
something like that uh I think that
that's pretty obvious but I would argue
that the Bitcoin community
got caught up in the exact same type of
mania that the uh the community around
Shibu Inu or GameStop or Dogecoin uh it
was the same mentality right you got to
buy it now you got to get on the train
because it's going to a million and if
you don't buy it now have fun staying
poor uh yes Bitcoin is significantly
different but unfortunately back then I
think the community
um fell into the same trap and I mean
you had people like sailor coming out
and said to mortgage your house mortgage
your house to buy Bitcoin and I and I
went on several podcasts uh back then
when the interviewer would ask me well
why not max out your credit card to buy
Bitcoin I'd be like
I I would have nothing because that's
such an insane question like I wouldn't
even know how to respond so
um definitely the the underlying asset
completely different but at the end of
the day we're all human beings
yeah maxing out your credit card to buy
anything that speculative is generally
not a good idea ask me how I know is one
of the biggest settlement companies in
Canada it's like a lot of people show up
with that problem
oh yeah you yeah you've been on the
other side of that yeah I forgot with
your your past business yeah yeah so I
saw a lot of people uh not understanding
the basics of the credit card machine I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out